hey i'm @nerdist an diego in the thick
of comic-con now star wars battlefront
is a featured sponsor here and the game
and AMD were nice enough to let me get a
sneak peak at an alpha build of the game
suck me into a 20 v 20 multiplayer match
on the planet of Hoth I'm gonna park
this somewhere and said we can go get
our hands on the game does anyone know
where valet is a I get ballet for this
this is the first battlefront title
since dice took over and we know them
and love them for their work on a
battlefield which is awesome and they
brought a lot of that kind of
multiplayer polish to this so far you
still don't know everything and we
probably loan until the game is released
on november seventeenth but we do know
that we're going to be able to be on
half as i was we're going to be on Endor
we're going to be on a planet jakku oh
here come the grenades will not let me
back up right now I'm patched into 20 be
20 upstairs and nerd HQ and you know I'm
getting my snow trooper helmet handed to
me but I'm new to this just learning at
learning the mechanics really like
ability to switch back and forth between
first and third person view
this is one that I've been waiting for
like this is one that as soon as we
heard about it in 2013 I think they they
acknowledge that this game was being
developed battlefield fans shooter fans
and obviously Star Wars fans got excited
now Star Wars games have been fantastic
nice to the old republic Star Wars games
have been not so great certain connect
titles that were available for the xbox
360 but this is one that seems to really
kind of ride the line this is it I'm
going out in a blaze of glory you going
out in a blaze of snow no I'm going out
in the Hills blaster fire that's what it
is thought it was glory it's just lasers
and that's it for me in star wars
battlefront not going to say I didn't
have a good time just going to say it
was a laser sponge
you